It's Odell Beckham Jr.,
we're playin' Start Bench Cut.
I'm gonna be given a category—
I'mma have to pick one to start,
one to bench and one to cut.
I'mma start, you know,
I'm from New Orleans so, "Tha Carter III," I'mma start it.
I'mma bench "The Blueprint" cuz it was—
it's up there.
And, umm, you know, as much as I love
"Get Rich or Die Tryin'" and what it did for me during that time,
I'mma have to cut it only because we're in this game.
Man, what about, uhh, "Any Given Sunday"?
You didn't even throw it in there.
All right, I'd take "Rudy" out,
cuz I can't remember "Rudy" at the moment.
"Friday Night Lights" I'll cut.
I'll bench "Remember the Titans," cuz—
classic and it was my favorite.
And "Any Given Sunday," I'll have to start it.
Umm, Al Pacino, Jamie Foxx, Willie Beamen and, umm,
Lawrence Taylor was in it. It just was a hard movie to me.
Ahh, I mean, I remember Al Pacino's speech and how it kinda,
you know, I'm in the locker room and I can hear that
and I can feel that.
And it was something that was relatable and he was kinda talkin' about
one moment and one opportunity and, umm, you know, it's really like that.
Man, s--t.
I love Serena, but
I'mma have to put her there.
It's tough to go against Tom, bro, he's really the GOAT, like, he,
he really does that, you know, so—
but I can't start him over Tiger, so it's like
I gotta give 'em, like, equal playin' time or somethin'.
And, and we won't—
we won't cut Serena, we'll bench her
and we'll share the playin' time between Tom Brady and Tiger Woods.
I'm Odell Beckham Jr., and that was Start Bench Cut.